welcome to friends select school my name
is Bob Cotter I'm the director of
institutional advancement at the school
and I'm pleased to welcome you on behalf
of Rose Hagan the head of the school in
the entire community two years ago we
began a relationship with Joseph Fox
bookstore which has resulted in a series
of events such as tonight's michael fox
is an alumnus of friends select and we
are delighted to help support he and his
mother Madeline as they run the premiere
independent bookstore in the area if
you're not on our mailing list for such
events please feel free to sign up out
in the lobby and we'll make sure that we
let you know about future events when
they happen tonight you're going to hear
from James Hirsch followed by Reuben
Carter and then they will have answered
questions for a brief period as many as
possible but they want to leave enough
time to be able to sign all of the books
that people want to sign at the end of
the question and answer period both
James and Reuben will be in the room
across the hall from the theater and
will set up a line so that you can
purchase books from Joseph Fox books and
then have them signed due to time
constraints they will only be able to
sign books and not any other kinds of
memorabilia and we appreciate your
cooperation with that if you do not wish
to have a book signed at the end of the
talk you can leave through the door
which is at the back right of the
auditorium and that will take you out to
17th Street when Michael Fox called me
to tell me the possibility of this event
I said yes immediately we knew nothing
about a movie at the time let alone that
Denzel would be in it
growing up in the 60s and 70s and I wish
I could say as a very young person in
the 60s and 70s but I can't I was both
moved and angered by Rubin Carter story
I felt then and I still do that it was a
story about America that people needed
to hear and I couldn't understand why
more people didn't know about it
fortunately for us James Hirsch has told
that very complicated story in a
powerful book that I strongly urge you
to read James S Hirsch is a former
reporter for The Wall Street Journal in
The New York Times and hurricane is his
first book please welcome James Hirsch
well thank you very much for coming out
tonight it's good to be here by the year
and a half ago Reuben and I traveled to
New York to talk to publishers about our
story proposal at the time Reuben and I
had spent many hours on the telephone
he lives in Toronto and I live in Boston
but we hadn't yet met face to face so I
booked us in a rather modest hotel in
two small rooms and I went to meet him
for the first time Reuben opened up the
door and he gives me this great big bear
hug
but then he steps back and he gestures
around his rather under sized room it
gives me that hard stare he shakes his
head and says Jim what is this my prison
cell was bigger than this room
I was I was summarily fired as his
travel agent but I did get to write the
book I'm gonna speak for just a few
minutes about the book and then give way
to Reuben so why a book about Reuben
Carter before I began this project that
was like many people in this country and
that I was familiar with the outlines of
Reubens life he's been a top-rated boxer
in the 1960s when he was he was arrested
for triple homicide in New Jersey
despite his claims of innocence he was
convicted of that crime over the years
he became a cause celeb as Bob Dylan
Muhammad Ali and many others rallied to
his support nonetheless Ruben spent
almost 20 years in prison before his
conviction was overturned and he was
eventually fully exonerated that's what
I knew of Rubens story when my agent
called me in June of 1998 and told me
that Ruben might be willing to work with
an author in a story about his life so I
went out I began reading everything that
had been written about Ruben and started
talking to some of his friends and
lawyers then I called Ruben myself now
he didn't know me from Adam so I just
introduced myself and I said Ruben I
don't think your story has been told yet
and I'd like to tell it well Ruben did
not exactly jump at this offer he
doesn't trust people very
readily but we we began talking and
finally I said if I do this project I
have just one demand I need to be able
to walk through every door in your life
and write what I find and Ruben said I
have nothing to hide so he got the ball
rolling what drew me to this story
Rubens life has taken him through a
series of inherently dramatic venues the
army the boxing ring the courtroom the
prison and the action from these venues
propels the narrative along there also a
lot of surprises in the book such as how
Ruben became a gunrunner for Steven Biko
South African resistance but these were
not the subplots that most interested me
whether I was fascinated by Rubens
struggle with in his own search for
meaning in a world that seemed to be a
thin film of false reality we were
speaking with a reporter that this
morning and she said to Ruben did the
world seem strange to you after 20 years
in prison and Ruben said the world
seemed strange to me even before I got
to prison you see even before Ruben was
arrested for this crime his life had
been defined by his anger and his
bitterness after he was put in prison he
spent years raging against his captors
but when the charges against Ruben were
finally dropped and he was exonerated he
gave a speech in New York an excerpt of
which is on the back of the book and in
talking to this audience people were
expecting him to denounce his
adversaries who had kept and kept him in
prison for all those years and he asked
himself the question he asked the
audience the question he said am i
bitter when Ruben said bitterness only
concerns the vessel that contains it and
for me to permit our control bitterness
to control my life in any way whatsoever
would be to allow those who put me in
prison for 22 years to take even more
than the time they were already taken
now that would make me an accomplice to
their crime
well when I read that I realized that if
I could find out what happened to Ruben
in prison I'd have one hell of a yarn
the miraculous journey of Rubin Carter
refers to two separate but parallel
journeys one through the criminal
justice system and one more personal
spiritual Odyssey safer Ruben fighting
for his innocence was easy fighting for
his dignity against the strictures of
prison was more difficult but fighting
for his heart's ease for peace of mind
her some meaning to his life that had
been the hardest fight yet I was with
Ruben a while back when a boxing fan
asked him who was your toughest fight
against and Ruben said myself and that's
what this book is about I'm closing on
just make one last comment I did walk
through every door in Rubens life I
spent hundreds of hours with Ruben both
on the phone and in person they
interviewed about 120 people who knew
Ruben both his friends and his
adversaries I read through thousands of
pages of court documents prison military
and police records plus Rubens personal
journals and letters I did not sugarcoat
what I found as chronicled Rubens
achievements as well as his
disappointments his triumphs as well as
his mistakes but through this long
process of research and inquiry I
developed a great deal of personal
respect and admiration for Ruben as I
repeatedly was shown his strength of
character my scent Ruben the manuscript
I was skittish about what he would think
of this rather gritty portrait of his
life and I realized that regardless of
how many people buy the book or what the
critics write or what my publisher
thought or even what my wife said there
was only one true judge of this book if
Ruben Carter didn't think I had captured
his story not only the facts but also
the spirit of his life and this book
would have been a failure
so I sent Ruben the manuscript another
thing you need to know about Ruben is he
night owl and he will often call me in
the wee hours of the morning just to
chat so at 1 a.m. on this night the
phone rings so I roll out of bed and I
go to the phone I pick it up hey Jim
this is brewed I just want you to know
I'm about to begin
your book I said ok room hi I hope you
enjoy it good night I go back to bed a
half hour later the phone rings again I
roll out of bed I pick up the phone and
it's Ruben and he's in a state of high
excitement and he says Jim I finished
the first chapter and I think it's great
you're a very clever writer and I know
where you're going with this story and
he and he he goes on in this vein for
some time and finally I say rube I'm
glad you like it but you don't have to
call me after each chapter
Ruben read the manuscript three times
and he did not ask for a single change
in the book and when he told me Jim this
book is a roadmap to enlightenment I
knew that no matter what this book does
in the marketplace I realized my goal
and satisfied most important judge of
all it's my honor to introduce Rubin
hurricane Carter
yeah
thank you thank you Wow maybe you are
the way we ought to try it at a gym
I love it I love it it is indeed ladies
and gentlemen a great honour privilege
and a great pleasure Wow we got people
up there too Wow and a great pleasure
for me to be here this evening at fringe
select school and Philadelphia
Pennsylvania long way from Trenton state
prison I could tell you that not too far
across the river but at least it's
crossed the river after struggling given
my history for the last 63 years of my
life constantly struggling with mindless
knuckleheaded human beings just gnarly
escaping the electric chair being
branded as a racist triple murderer when
you really come to think about it it's a
great pleasure for me to be anywhere
and since I am somewhat weary thanks to
him
thanks to him he got me out of high on a
book trail when I should be out there
helping people and I'm out here getting
publicity since I've been talking for
weeks and weeks and weeks and can't talk
much more I would like to tell you three
stories and these stories will tell us
where people are today where they can be
and where they was and once there was a
little boy who was walking in the fields
of his father and happened upon an
eagle's egg that had fallen from the
mountains high above surrounding the
tiny village the boy picked the eagle's
egg up took it home with him and placed
it in the nest amongst his prairie
chickens and lo and behold the little
equal it hatched amongst the booth of
prairie chickens he learned how to
scratch in the earth for seeds and
insects to eat they learned how to crack
and cackle and learn how to fly in brief
spurts of a flapping of the wing and
then come crashing back to the earth
because that's the way prairie chickens
act don't they before long the prairie
chicken scratching in the dirt who old
and tired and tough and one day was he
was scratching in the dirt for something
to eat he looked up in the sky and saw a
Oh floating on the wind currents
majestically and the now big Eagle
clucked to his his prairie chicken
neighbor who was also scratching in the
earth for season and 60 is it my wait a
beautiful creature what is that what
kind of what kind of creature is that it
is so big it is so huge and it is
magnificent and the prairie chicken
neighbor scratching in the dirt too busy
trying to get something to eat said look
don't you fade out any mind no pay any
attention
that's the eagle that's the king of the
birds but you can never be like that
and so the now big and old Eagle never
thought again about it and died
stretching and earth as a prairie
chicken that's what we as human beings
on this earth do scratch in the dirt for
seeds and insects to eat as though we
were prairie chickens when we are all
actually eagle and the reason why we
remain prairie chickens is because six
human beings trapped in happenstance in
the dark and bitter cold each one
possessed the stick of water or so the
stories told their dying fire in need of
logs the first woman held hers back four
of all the faces around the fire she
noticed that one of them were black the
next man looking across the way saw not
one member of his church and couldn't
bring himself to give the fire piston of
birch the third man sat in tattered
clothes he gave his
why should mastic of would be used to
warm the idle rich the rich man just sat
back and thought of all the wealth he
had in store and how he can keep what he
had earned from the lazy and shiftless
poor the black man's face bespoke of
revenge as their fire faded from sight
for all he could see in his stick of
wood was a chance to spite the whites
the last man in this for long who did
not accept for game given only to those
who gave is how he played the game the
logs held tight and deaths steel hands
was proof of human sin they didn't die
from the cold without they died from the
cold with them and that's what we all
did that's exactly what he did
then there was a a big man a heavy man
who fell asleep one night while shelling
peas in the cramped quarters of his
hovel in the hut mysteriously caught on
fire in the village people rushed to the
scene to try to save the sleeping man
before his house could burn to the
ground but they couldn't do it because
the house was too small and the man was
too big to move so as they were
struggling trying to save the sleeping
man before the house could burn to the
ground the village wise man happened
upon the scene and saw this struggling
mass trying to save this sleeping man he
just Haleh wake him up just wake him up
and he'll save himself you see those
three things are exactly what we do to
ourselves we talk about a new millennium
well as a convicted racist murderer
just narrowly accepted escape from the
electric chair and spending 20 years in
prison
I come to realize that in order for us
to survive that we must wake up all of
us must wake up that we are in a virtual
Garden of magic a paradise we are
actually in a paradise where anything
that you can possibly dream in your mind
and can see and work towards it can
indeed be achieved my lit my being here
tonight is living is living proof that
absolutely living proof of that that in
we are limited only by our own
imagination this is a world of unlimited
possibilities and there is nothing that
we can't do on this earth nothing that
we can't do and the only reason why we
don't do it is because we have too much
heavy baggage on us to fly like the
Eagles that we are
that excess baggage is the fact that I'm
an email and you're she meant that I'm
black and your wife are you red or you
yellow you're brown that um I'm a
Democrat you're a Republican I'm I'm
independent I'm German I'm African
you're Dutch I'm French you know we all
live under the power of Kundalini have
you ever heard the power of Kundalini
the power of Kundalini comes from a rich
magician who own sheep and had problems
because the Sheep kept running away they
didn't like the fact that the that the
man Kundalini wanted their meat and fur
they didn't like that so they had sex
they ran away so the magician had a
problem that he had to solve and he
solved he hypnotized is she he told one
sheep you are not a sheep and I do not
want your meat and I do not want your
fur you are a lion the next chief I said
you're a tiger the next chief you're an
eagle the next you are bear and the mad
magician had no more problems
the Sheep stop running away but that's
where we are we are under the power of
hypnosis on this planet the power of
Kundalini the power of trying to be
everything else but what we really are
we want to be black and white and green
and purple and Jewish and Italian and
African we want to be all those things
and we are none of those things in fact
it is those very things that keep us
from the essence of ourselves that keep
us from flying way off this planet
high to the atmosphere if everyone in
this room's excess baggage will just lay
down at your feet just lay it down on
your feet don't worry about anybody
taking it because everybody has
don't worry about that don't worry about
it if we could just lay these things
down in this so-called new millennium if
we can lay these things down everybody
in this room would immediately begin to
levitate everybody would be immediately
be gentle levity and we would live in a
world where human beings love and
understand of the human beings just
human beings we all belong to the same
human family every one of us and the
only reason why we don't understand that
is because we are sleeping we are
sleeping people we need to wake up to
save ourselves because we continue to
follow the old math way of putting in
time and in advocating responsibility
then ain't no change gonna come you see
people love change and hate it at the
same time what we really want is for
everything to get better but still
remain the same that's what we want and
in order to do that in this new
millennium we must lay down all of our
excess baggage and at the old millenium
and so we can enter into this new length
this new millennium clean just as the
two monks who were walking down in the
forest one day on their way to a retreat
a young bar and Nova and these monks
just happened to belong to a set of
monks that practice celibacy abstinence
and as they was walking through this
through the woods they happened upon
this raging stream and a woman standing
on the side of the bank afraid to get in
the water afraid to be swept away well
the old monk just bent down and a woman
climbed up on his back they waited
across the water got on the other side
the old ma bent down the woman climbed
on his back off his back and the two
months went on the way and a woman went
on her way but the young monk was
agitated he couldn't understand what he
had just saw he couldn't understand and
finally he could hold his tongue no
longer he said tell me old man tell me
how does it feel to break your vows of
celibacy for so many years how does it
feel to carry a beautiful woman how does
it feel to have her warm arms wrapped
around your neck a breath on your air a
soft breast pressing against your back
her thighs wrapped around your waist
tell me old man how does it feel to
carry a beautiful woman an old man
looked at the young monk who said
perhaps it is you who should tell me I
would kill to carry a beautiful woman
you see I put the woman down back there
at the river but obviously you are still
carrying
we must if we intend to save ourselves
the people and I'm serious about this if
we intend to save ourselves we have to
wake up and we have to put all the dis
foolishness aside all of these things
that that has kept us apart for all of
these many years while we were still
laboring under the false pretense that
we are the home of the free and the home
of the brave that's [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] we are not in beg my
pardon I don't mean to I don't mean to
insult anybody by using that word but
it's true it is true we can we do have
the ability to be better than we are
much much better than we are we have the
ability to provide shelter support
encouragement and love to everybody you
see hey put me in prison but love bust
me up
love now love I know this kind of
strangers all punch on firefighter face
talking like this but love cures all
people both those who give it and those
who received and it is love that we need
to connect ourselves up to and I'm
serious I I don't I don't want to preach
because I'm not a preacher my families
are preachers I am NOT and my family is
here tonight to a whole lot of merry
night hi
so there's one last ditty one last duty
that I want to say because it's really
miraculous in fact my entire life has
been miraculous and that's why Jim has
coined his book hurricane the miraculous
journey of Rubin Carter and they had
ended it has indeed being miraculous now
I used being past it only to make a
point because this is not the
combination of my life this is just the
beginning you know we are going on
through here but I forgot what I suppose
a man hey wait
oh no I'm not gonna talk about that yeah
yeah no Jim was telling me or when I
said that my life is miraculous Jim
wanted me to say and let me tell you why
because for the last 20 years I have
been reviled as a triple racist murderer
locked down in Trenton state prison for
the rest of my life just narrowly
escaping the electric chair
and just a couple of weeks ago I was
invited to the White House and I don't
black house clap right out
and there was and there I was sitting
next to the President of the United
States the most influential person on
the face of this earth engaged in him in
serious critical conversation about
things that's taking place in the world
today so close to him that I can hear
every breath he took and Monday I'll be
adjusted in the General Assembly of the
United Nations
now if that's not miraculous if that's
not miraculous I don't know what is so
this last didn't because it's important
it's important to me I think this is one
of the most important things that ever
happened to me in my life when I was
sure see I wrote the books that made up
this movie I wrote the movie script and
made up just moving all that so this
didn't come to me by on his own nothing
comes to you by accident accidents
happen all over the place they never
happened in a straight line
never and that's why we all live under
the law of accident but when I was
certain that this movie was finally
going to be made I said to myself ok
Denzel Washington and that Denzel
Washington was gonna be is gonna betray
me and I tell you I'd never knew how
good I look until I saw
when I was positive when I was positive
that Denzel was going to play me
I knew that Denzel would have to come to
me and ask for my instructions on how to
play me I mean how would Denzel
Washington know how it feels to be
dashed from the top of the world to the
very bottom of the world locked away in
prison how would Denzel Washington know
how it feels to be snatched away from
your beautiful wife and your
three-year-old child and be branded at a
triple racist murderer
how would Denzel Washington know how
that done so I said he's gonna have to
come to me he's gonna have to do it and
if he doesn't do it he's a dork but
lowering the whole it didn't happen the
way I thought it would happen we met
Denzel and I and we began talking and we
talked about everything and we flew from
Toronto to California from California to
New York from New York back to Toronto
talking all the time and one day after a
rather intensive five or six hour
conversation
circling the globe two or three times we
stopped for lunch and walked around the
corner of the four seasons in Toronto to
to a very expensive restaurant for which
I'm I'm glad that Denzel was paying the
bill
after lunch I excused myself and I went
to the restroom and when I came out I
found Denzel in the four-year in the
hallway of this restaurant just looking
at himself in the mirror just staring at
himself no well I thought he wanted to
be alone so so I went back to the table
and and when Denzel came back to the
table
we continued to talk and the more we
talked the better I began to like him
even above what I already liked him I
mean this was a real emotional circuit I
said I like I like the way he moved
I liked his vocabulary I liked his fancy
I loved history and I love this laughter
I love I said my god I'm loving this man
I said well maybe I've been in prison
too long
and then it hit me like a double left
hook and a straight right cross when I
came out of the restroom I found ends up
in the hallway staring in the mirror he
was clearing his canvas in preparation
of portraying me and when he said when
he came back to the table and sat down
from that very second he was giving me
back to me and I was loving what I saw I
was loving me you know that was the
greatest if this movie does nothing as
Jim said if his book bombs in the store
what it brought and what it provided is
good enough well if this movie fails
that's good enough for me because what I
saw was something that I had been loving
all my life but had never seen and never
seen before and when I saw it I said Wow
and from that moment on and from that
moment on I begin to up like I love me I
began to send myself for bouquets of
flowers
every single week one flower is called
truth the other flower is called truth
and friendship the other flowers got the
other book is called truth friendships
surrounded by love and the fourth
bouquet was good you see
truth leads to good most people think
that that good comes from truth it is
not so whenever the Creator is described
in any language in any text the Creator
is always described as I am good and
therefore everything must flow from good
so truth comes from good and if you
follow that truth if you follow those
principles if you follow those laws that
truth can lead you to the level of good
but when they get to the level of good
you got to leave the truth alone and
operate from the level of good you must
be good not up like you good be and if
you be good if all of us being good we
will live in a good good place where
everybody will be educated
everybody will be supported everybody
will have a job no one will be
discriminated against for any reason
whatsoever because we are all nothing
but human beings with not days
we're not blacks we're not whites we're
not cops
we're not crooks where we are human
beings and are the whole raison d'être
of being a human being is not to remain
a human being because human being a
human being my friends is a greatly
overrated commodity
greatly overrated commodity because it
is human beings who hate one another
it's human beings who fight one another
who raped and robbed one another who do
all these terrible terrible things to
one another and therefore our mission in
life is not to remain human beings but
to be but to be a human becoming a human
becoming something of the than a human
being and that should be our quest for
this new millennium where we'll have no
more racism will have no more death
penalty will have no more Mumia
abu-jamal
sitting on death row
if but that one virtue love could be
made universal the strong would not prey
upon the weak the deceitful would not
prey upon the simple men would commit no
robberies Chiefs of families would
commit no assertions in fact one
virtually love to be made universal we
would be the greatest preachers on the
face of this earth we have the ability
to do that and to be that we really
really have the ability if anyone can
from a prison cell tract for 20 years
overcome his obstacles overcome all of
the adversity overcome whatever is
needed to overcome if I can do it you
can do it and if you don't do it it's
because you don't want to do it and if
you don't want to do it then step aside
and let those who do want to do it do
you see
we have two kinds of people in this
world the watches and the doers and the
watches sit around watching the doers do
so if you can't do it get out of the way
and let those of us who are willing to
commit our lives to it do it thank you
I'm probably not the best one to judge
this but from where I was standing I
think Ruben looks a hell of a lot better
than Denzel Washington
now Jim had Jim had suggested that
Reuben might go a little bit longer than
he originally said he would because
they've been traveling together for a
while so we'll have time for a few
questions so what I'd ask is that if you
have a question if you raise your hand
and I'll call and if you would stand and
talk as loud as you could thank you
right there question I saw the hurricane
and it's one of the best movies I've
and I'm so grateful it was made because
I found out about you a little bit about
these three wonderful people from Canada
because we saw the movie also and it
blew us away and it is an Oscar
contender there's no doubt about it
well actually the three people was a
composite of 13 people and and we had to
we had to make a composite of them in
order to protect them while they were
doing their investigating of my case and
that's why we just sent returned called
in the Canadians but the real story of
the hurricane is in the salvation of the
hurricane is three three people two
teenagers young black teenager John
artist who was captured with me and who
had never been in trouble with the law
before and when just graduated from high
school and was on his way to college on
a scholarship for football and track he
was a highly acclaimed Anthony and from
the moment that we were stopped on June
17th 1966 John artisans medal was tested
because John artists could have walked
away from there at any second
all he had to do was to say that that
loudmouth the prizefighter that that
ball had a guy that hits everybody and
hits himself as well committed this
crime and I would be dead and John
artist would been free but he probably
would have double-crossed him anyway
killed them too but it's only because of
John artists and the creative course
that I'm here so John artists throughout
the 15 years that he spent in prison
contracting incurable blood disorder and
today he has fingers and toes
amputated if John artist would have said
at any moment that Rubin Carter had
anything to do with this woman Carter
would be dead right now
in fact the Governor of New Jersey
Governor Brendan Bird brought John
artist out of his house five days before
Christmas and set him down in front of
his mother and father and his brothers
and sisters and promised guaranteed that
if John given incriminating to get
statement against me he would be home
for Christmas and John artists responded
my mother and father didn't teach me to
lie they taught me to tell the truth
so John artist is my hero he saved my
life
John saved my life until a 15 year old
ghetto urgent letter Martin trapped in
the ghettos of bedford-stuyvesant New
York came across this group of Canadians
that we were talking about who was down
from Canada working on the device to
perfect a gas saving device and they met
lesra at the EPA lab in in Brooklyn when
I was working as a summer job and they
came in a group close to this youngster
and they listened to his aspirations and
his dreams and Leslie was third in his
great in Brooklyn class of 43rd he was
considered to be an honor student and
yet the Canadians were dumbfounded when
they found out that the board couldn't
read or write or speak a single word of
standard English he didn't even know the
name of the country so these Canadians
were were remind Bobby doesn't happen to
speak how could this jump stir achieve
or attain his dreams if he doesn't know
how
we uh doesn't know how to write so they
went to his mother and father he's
bothered by the way happened to be the
lead singer of the del biking due up you
know go with me you have a Nassau well
his father Earl is I'd love my claim to
fame is being innocent not a singer so
the father in the parents are glad that
one of their siblings is going to
extinct this ghetto gave the Canadians
permission to bring lesra back to Canada
and to educate him properly not to miss
educate him but educate him properly and
as they were teaching a letter about his
rich African heritage they gave a
richard wright to read wah to read
Franklin read Frederick Douglas to read
all of these kinds of books to read and
less it happened upon my autobiography
and which I wrote while I was in prison
and sent it out over the 40-foot prison
walls into the ocean of life hoping upon
hope that someone someday would see this
bobbin bottle in the ocean of life pick
it up read my message and come to help
me and lesser Martin did exactly that he
came and he brought his Canadian family
with them little did I know that by
answering Lazarus little teeny letter
that this young child would be the
catalyst upon which my freedom come that
is me nervous
that is never
mr. car is my you look great first of
all because of your experience can you
still keep an open mind when you hear
things for example the OJ Simpson trial
the Rae Carruth trial or does your mind
automatically say frame-up no no no no I
don't have an automatic mind you have an
automatic mind I do not have an
automatic mind my mind is awake my mind
is very conscious I am aware of Who I am
what I am and what you are and where we
are and what we can do where we are to
be what we supposed to be you see we are
planted here on organic life on Earth
flowers all of us each one of us is a
world within ourselves everything that
exists in this universe exists right
here in each one of us we don't have to
go to the moon or to the Sun or to Venus
in order to find the materiality there
we can just look on ourselves the
materiality is there that is our
spaceship through life that materiality
but we don't know that you see we think
that we've been put here simply as a
punishment maybe or for some other
reason but we are here for great
experiment and Jim was telling me to cut
so our world
he he does not decide someone's
innocence or guilt by the headlines in
the paper because that's what happened
to him
and he knows not to make that mistake
again we get the talking we got to talk
in cooler sit down and have a fireside
talk face-to-face you let me tell you
about joey giardello
I fought Joey Joey and I fought right
here in Philadelphia at the convention
center in 1964 December 1964 for the
middleweight championship and Joey is a
tremendous prize fighter as well as a
tremendous human being in fact oh this
is a fight in town Philly
oh man this is where I started my stuff
right here in Philly but I got ran out
of town by Sonny Liston I did that's the
truth we still all train at the same gym
at that time Lynn Matthews was the light
heavyweight Lynn Matthews was the light
weight champ
Charlie Scott was the welterweight champ
Gil Turner was the number one two
middleweight contender Harold Johnson
was the light heavyweight champ and
Sonny Liston was the heavyweight chair
and we used to all trained and I was
just thought and I had one fight and you
know there's a hierarchy in professional
fighting preliminary fighters do not
hang out with the contenders and the
champion is just I'll do that you just
don't do that but one day in the gym
Sonny was getting ready for a television
fight in Madison Square Garden and his
sparring partners didn't show up that
day none of them see they was smart they
were very smart so Sonny had no sparring
partners until a little ball hit it
would be prizefighter looked up into the
ring at Sonny and said open his big
mouth and said I'll spar with you Sonny
and Sonny look down at me with that
baleful stare I don't care and the way
we went I mean we did some humping
we do some liver that Jim was smoking
you know because Sonny was big and he
was quick and he could punch it ha and I
was sort of known as one of the hardest
punches in the middleweight division and
as a matter of fact one of the hardest
punches in the
price by the game so Sonny had to hit me
to keep me off of him and every day we
began to spawn at one after another and
after one intensive spawn session
sweating like a dog I went back to the
corner and took my headgear off and my
head gave was full of blood my eye was
bleeding from my ears and I said Ruben
now there's hard-headed and there's
hard-headed this guy's gonna kill you
so I picked up that night and left
Philadelphia on the first thing smoke I
knew I knew that if I stayed there I
would have to spar with Sonny again cuz
he was my friend and he needed to work
and so did I but I just didn't do it I
had to run
so this town here is one of the greatest
fighters in the whole world everybody is
scared of Philadelphia fighters
Philadelphia fighters are a wrecking
crew of the boxing world the demolition
the demolition squad of the boxing world
and I don't understand why we have so
much problems here with all you could
fight it we was talking about joey
giardello joey is just one of those
kinds of fighters Joey could fight and
he had a lot of a lot of suits but when
I fought Joey and lost Joey I lost the
fight Joey didn't win the fight I lost
the fight because I didn't fight my
fight I fought Joey's fight I was trying
to bucks Joey and Joey could clearly
outbox me and he did and therefore I did
not win the time I didn't fight my fight
I said I got to go 15 rounds why do I
have to go 15 rounds about the end of
the one it doesn't make any sense to me
but when you put a certain mind
said in your head when you condition
yourself for a certain way it becomes a
habit and there's only one thing in the
world that have worked for us for
nothing not even a fool works for
nothing one thing and that's a habit you
just let that habit get established and
it'll operate even though you're walking
around in a trance and that's what's
wrong with us
habitually doing wrong to other people
habitually miss then misunderstanding of
the people and it is the
misunderstanding that is causing all the
continued
Oh Oh Ruben my name is Maurice and I've
been through the flight that you've been
through
I represent like a handful of brothers
that have been incarcerated that have
come home gotten my life together I work
at PNC Bank around the corner and I work
for um youth mentoring program called
the school of hard knocks um he was
speaking on about you know the hate
within and I could relate to that
because for like I was locked up I was
incarcerated for four years and for two
long years I was the laziest you know my
mind-state was not what it should be you
know um I came home in the summer in 97
I've been out over two years and every
son you know we represent we go down to
you study center here on 24 Pennsylvania
try to give back a handful of like so
many people here to come out to support
you we try to support those who are in
the same situation that we've been in
half um homicides have rape cases have
drug cases things that uh that a lot of
people take for granted but a lot of
that we come to find out that a lot of
them are just misunderstood you know you
were just speaking and I can relate to
that because for I'm 27 years old you
celebrate my 27th birthday last December
and um you know what you're saying is
really touching me because I've been
there and I know what it's like that you
know have all this rage up inside me but
now you know I try to give back to those
who are less fortunate to myself you
know like you said we get blessing from
God every time we do something positive
you know all the good that we do you
know shows back on our community you
know and I just
we get blessings from the Creator
whether we do good or bad because the
Creator maintains the life force within
us and as long as we have that life
force within us my brother 99% of the
problem is solved and that little 1%
dealing with other human beings
that's like [ __ ] like stuff man light
stuff we can do it we can do it but did
you know and do all of you know that in
this country one out of every three
young black men in this country between
the ages of 12 and 27 are under the
control of the criminal justice system
one out of three one out of three that's
outrageous there are more young black
men they're young more young black men
in prison in this country than there are
in this universities that's sad the
prisons have become assembly lines of
death in this country there are death
camps set up all around this country and
it is killing people every single day
every single day and we don't know
anything about it we turn our eyes from
we must not turn our eyes from we have
to be aware of what's going on in our
lives and going on in our countries
because it affects all of us if one of
us is poor with all four buses hungry
we're all if one of us isn't in prison
illegally then we're all in prison
illegally
we all must be brothers and sisters to
one another we just have to do that it's
not worth it being angry when you're
angry and bitter and me it only hurts
you it doesn't hurt the person and we
keep rejecting that anger and it doesn't
hurt the person who you reject any
version
- it's like a toothache your toothache
that doesn't hurt your wife your
daughter your children your son it
doesn't even hurt the dentist in fact
the dennis is gonna hurt you and be paid
for
that's what anger is that's what
bitterness is and it's just not worth it
listen I was the anguish rascal on this
planet
angry man mean I was mean I was mean and
I would fight I would fight because I
would protect myself and I feel that
everybody has the right to protect
themselves and should protect themselves
and if you can take an old war horse
like me and turning it and turn our
hurricane into a gentle breeze then
that's what we want to go let's stick
with love I guess the guy get out of
here inside me
there's some if you'll give them a
minute they'll they'll get across the
hallway and there'll be two lines one
for books that are signed and one for
books to be purchased Thanks